welcome to cern home of the world's
largest particle collider and the
workplace of physicists like maria
gironi
roughly 14 billion years ago the big
bang created the universe the existence
of time solar systems like earth
and even life itself that's correct
today physicists at cern are recreating
conditions similar to those just after
the big bang in hopes of answering the
many mysteries of the universe
[Music]
terna is very well known in the past
years for the discovery of the higgs
boson
this discovery led to a nobel prize for
francois englert and peter higgs and
it's all thanks to the large hadron
collider the largest machine on earth
but wait
what exactly does a particle collider do
imagine that the particles are tennis
balls
and those tennis balls are launched at
near the speed of light from one side of
the galaxy before colliding into more
tennis balls coming from the other side
of the galaxy
this creates conditions similar to those
of the big bang
[Music]
the results of particle collisions are
studied in experiments like the cms
this is the cms experiment
the data it gathers helps scientists in
their search for things like extra
dimensions dark matter and new particles
like the higgs
there's a lot of unanswered questions
they still remain unknown to us
so they turned up the beam
increasing the number of collisions
billions of collisions happen each
second which generate a huge amount of
data
that huge amount of data needs to be
processed and fast before it's lost
forever
this is steve palowski from micron
micron and cern are working together in
a public-private partnership called cern
open lab cern is testing micron's deep
learning accelerator to help filter
through billions of particle collisions
in real time what we really want to do
is find the data that looks interesting
and peculiar and downright different
than what anybody has seen before
some of the greatest scientific
revelations come from unexpected results
penicillin the microwave chocolate chip
cookies were an accidental invention
this ems experiment was one of the two
experiments which discovered the diggs
boson
who knows what we will find next
[Music]